Now that you understand the components of the diffuse reflection model give
them a try. In the demo that follows we'll use the terms KA, and KD in the
reflection equation. These are simply numbers used to scale the effect of the
ambient and diffuse contributions up and down. KA is the greyscale level of the
ambient light and KD is handy way to modify the diffuse contribution. To sum up
the equation we use for this demo it's fragment color equals KA times material
plus KD times material times N.L. This is actually a bit simplified from what
3JS allows. In 3JS, you can inset an entirely different ambient color, though
to be honest, this is a peculiar thing to do. Also, in this demo, you'll a see
different color space used. Instead of RGB, it's hue, saturation and lightness.
HSL for short. Hue means the color essentially. Saturation is how much the hue
is used. Lightness is a scale factor, letting you easily make the color itself
brighter or darker. Here's a visualization of the color space. The 3JS library
let's you use HSL to set colors. For example, this code gives a mustard color.
So go try out the demo. Vary the ambiant and diffuse contributions. Change the
material color. Move the view around and see the effect. It's worth your while
to catch your breath and play around a bit so that you truly understand this
reflection model.